christian delporte historien il est
professeur à l'université de versailles
saint quentin il publie un livre sur les
débats politiques ces émissions qui ont
fait l'opinion si on parlait avec
christian delporte
christian delporte vous publié début
mars chez flammarion un livre consacré
aux grands débats politiques vous sous
titré ces émissions qui ont fait
l'opinion alors évidemment les deux
grandes banques elles ont pensé des
débats giscard mitterrand de 74 et 80
est ce que comme vous le dites dans
votre ce titre ils ont fait l'opinion en
tout cas ils ont mobilisé à chaque fois
un nombre de téléspectateurs
considérable alors c'est vrai pour tous
les grand débat de l'entre-deux tours
mais c'est vrai également pour
ses face à face qui sont un mode des
missions typiquement français et qui
donne du spectacle et je crois que si
l'opinion se mobilisent autour d'eux
autour de ces face à face c'est d'abord
pour soutenir une certaine manière leur
champion il ya les convaincus qu'ils
regardent il ya les convaincus il y a je
crois que les débat s'est en grande
partie de l'adrénaline et des choeurs
qui s'affolent il est on a besoin de ça
voilà un rite initiatique certaine façon
a d'une certaine façon oui et d'ailleurs
vous savez que les débat de
l'entre-deux-tours maintenant sont
réglés de manière extrêmement précise
depuis que depuis 1981 le corps
mitterrand avait imposé à giscard
d'estaing vingt-et-une conditions
terribles terrible oui tout à fait aux
réalités mitterrand ne voulait pas du
débat à mitterrand était mitterrand
était plutôt favori dans les sondages
donc quand on fait un face à face qu'on
a plus à perdre qu'à gagner et puis
d'autre part mitterrand n'avait pas la
télévision alors que jusqu'à à d'aurel
ils ont été extrêmement télégénique et
sa 10è et puis il y avait le souvenir de
ceux surtout le souvenir de 74
mitterrand a intériorisé qu'il avait
perdu le débat or quand on regarde
objectivement les enquêtes d'opinion
avant le débat après le débat le
résultat ça ne bouge pas bouge pas et
elle savait bouge pas alors vous dites
c'est une c'est une habitude française
ces débats alors qu'on a toujours
l'impression que ça devient des états
unis alors c'est vrai que le premier
débat présidentiel a eu lieu en 1960 aux
états unis a même eu quatre entre
kennedy et dixon mais en fait en france
on n'a pas inventé
le côte à côte comme ça existe aux etats
unis puisque les candidats ne s'adresse
pas directement la parole mais sont
obligés de passer par un journaliste
alors qu'en france on a on a inventé
plus que le tête-à-tête le face à face
où les hommes ses tripes indirects
s'interpellent se lancent des invectives
et ça ça apparaît d'abord à la radio
puisque les premiers rangs débats ont
lieu notamment à europe numéro un
parce que ça s'appelait comme ça puis
rtl on est à 62 ans 65 également il y a
à l'occasion de l'élection
présidentielle des face à face et ça
arrive à la télévision à partir de 1966
et puis il y a après ces grandes
émissions des missions légales
les autres les trois vérités notamment
qui débouchent finalement qui donne le
modèle au débat 1974 et qui va créer
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire
c'est qu'on considère aujourd'hui
finalement que ce débat d'entre deux
tours fait partie du rituel républicain
en 2002 quand y'en a pas quand chirac
refuse de débattre avec le pen on est un
peu ont perdu on va on est un peu voilà
le priver de quelque chose absolument il
est très content de retrouver ce grand
moment d'émotion en 2007 absolument la
radio un peu en arrière vous dites voilà
ça commençait à la radio c'est vrai
qu'au fond il ya il m'a mise quand même
très forte du pouvoir sur la radio les
tribunaux sous de gaulle ça se
libéralise un peu pompidou c'est aussi
un peu à ce moment là que ça commence à
apparaître de la radio à la télévision
jusqu'au 65e show 58 65 les choses sont
claires l'opposition n'a pas droit à la
parole à tous les visiteurs cette
campagne de 65 c'est une sorte
d'ouverture seulement puisque pour la
première fois oui ruiz à chaque candidat
à deux heures pour s'exprimer en deux
semaines et on se dit mais il ya des
gens qui parlent aussi billy's le
général de gaulle à partir de là les
choses ne peuvent plus être comme avant
est donc plutôt que d'interdire à
l'opposition de s'exprimer on va la
mettre en opposition avec la majorité
dans le cadre de ce débat on va y aller
traire évidemment un petit règlement
parce que il ya les premiers débats en
66 mais des 67 années on arrête on
arrête c'est trop dangereux et il faut
attendre pompidou et surtout chaban
delmas et chaban qui n'est pas rien a
plaidé
le rts pour qu'enfin il y a une parole
qui se libère à travers ses émissions
régulières toutes les semaines qui à
tourner qui attire beaucoup de public
armes égales et trois filles rites et
ses os x y avait presque plus de
démissions politique tout au long de
l'année si je peux dire qu'il n'y en a
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est assez
concentrés pendant les campagnes
électorales mais il n'a peut-être un peu
moins il fait moins ces rendez vous
réguliers il faut dire également qu'il y
avait moins de chaînes de télévision
privée channels
and rain est quand même beaucoup de
téléspectateurs
mais c'est vrai que des grandes
émissions régulières
à 20h30
les émissions politiques il n'y en a
plus je vais
parce qu'aucune chaîne me prendra le
risque de d'avoir un une audience
réduite par la présence même de
politique nataliste alors il des grandes
surprises dans ce débat mais égale c1
par exemple de batte de faire un gars
fort on dit carrefour va gagner beaucoup
plus fort et finalement elle ne gagne
pas toujours celui qu'on attend quoi et
oui c'est pour ça que ces débats
ressemblent à des matches il y a le
faisait il ya le challenger et puis de
temps en temps le challenger balle
favoris et c'est ce qui se passe
notamment dans ce fameux débat que vous
évoquez entre edgar faure et gaston
defferre hormis à 73,2 de fer est
quelqu'un qui est un système qui fait
évidemment ne crève pas l'écran alors
que guerre forces aquitaine très très à
l'aise il pense effectivement qui va
balayer d'un seul coup
son ami parce que dans la vie sont
plutôt ami gaston defferre et puis en
fait pas du tout mais il ya un autre cas
plus intéressant c'est un 71 le premier
débat entre chirac et je marchais c'est
la première intervention de marché à la
télévision c'est la première
intervention de chirac on pense que le
brillant énarque va balayer
l'apparatchik marchait et encore une
fois ça ne se passe pas comme ça donc
vous voyez il ya du spectacle inattendu
et c'est pour ça qu'on aime le débat est
là il y avait d'abord souri dans notre
soutien c'est celui avec maurice clavel
messieurs les censeurs bonsoir qui n'est
pas typiquement un homme politique c'est
un philosophe est oui parce qu'en france
certains intellectuels à ce qu'on fait
dans les années 70 c'est le débat le
face à face est tellement apprécié qu'il
n'y a pas seulement face à face entre
hommes politiques mais également des
intellectuels ou des hommes
deux cultures et on se ce débat là c'est
le débat qui n'a pas eu lieu qui n'a
plus que
clavel est parti en claquant la porte
tout simplement parce que donc dans
cette émission avant le débat proprement
dit il y avait un film et ce film était
fait en fait par la variété de la vie
m'a dit bon il a été un petit peu
censuré et il a été un peu censure et on
a supprimé un mot il ne l'a pas supporté
et les parties et dont la presse s'est
déformé et parce qu'on ne parlait que de
ça et on en parle encore c'est à sort
pas c'est assez souvent dans les
archives télévisées alors il ya des
débats entre politique et puis après il
ya des émissions aussi comme l'heure de
vérité où il ya des face à face alors
entre les hommes politiques qui sont
invités et puis les journalistes oui bon
il y à l'interview de mais l'interview
peut se transformer en face à face
surtout lorsque l'homme politique
cherche que face à face avec
avec son intervieweur et peut-être
également parce que l'intervieweur
cherche aussi en tout cas considère que
l'homme politique est immense je juge
évoque là et c'est dans le livre
notamment
1984 et 1985 qui sont les deux premières
interventions de jean marie le pen à
l'heure de vérité et il y à cette
confrontation avec jean-louis
servan-schreiber en 84 avec franz
olivier giesbert en 85 qui veulent
absolument que prouver que d'une part
qu'il n'y a pas de connivence que le
plus raciste que le pen est ainsi tissé
mythe évidemment ça n'est plus une
interview c'est un véritable face à face
et et de même il peut ya voir j'ai
retenu également dansé dans ce livre
le dialogue avec
entre le président de la république et
un panel de français et on a
l'impression que c'est très très nouveau
ou pas du tout pas du tout
giscard d'estaing le faisait déjà en
1977 et notamment on retrouvera dans le
livre cette confrontation entre giscard
et 25 lycéens du lycée saint-exupéry de
lyon et on s'aperçoit que tout de même
ces jeunes là n'avaient pas froid aux
yeux il a eu beau parler avec le
président de la république il avait
quelque chose à dire et ils l'ont dit et
à tel point d'ailleurs que giscard n'a
jamais plu
est ce que justement dans cette
pensée de nouvelles foreuses raison de
le dire qu'elle avait déjà existé des
missions voulait les gens sont enfin les
hommes politiques sont face directement
aux français il n'y a pas un peu aussi
une part de déconsidération du
journalisme
oui peut-être peut-être alors les
journalistes on les fasse donc face à
face qui pose les questions que
le bonne journée je préfère la véritable
interview l'interview en face à face
avec l'homme politique mais quel rôle
joue petit dans un face à face ils
comptent les points et il est le
chronomètre
il est le losc britten
en france par aux états unis aux états
unis justement c'est le journaliste qui
nourrit le débat mais en france ce que
l'on attend c'est un dialogue musclé si
possible entre les deux protagonistes
bon donc ce n'est pas ça n'est pas une
forme valorisante pour les journalistes
et d'ailleurs il faut bien dire que à
partir de la fin des années 70 et les
années 80 le face-à-face proprement dit
a plutôt tendance à reculer y en a de
temps en temps il ya ce fameux face à
face entre fabius et chirac en 85e il y
à nous amener à sa fin seulement les
face-à-face entre bernard tapie jean
marie le pen et caetera et c'est ce que
je trouvais ça amusant c'est que
aujourd'hui
après que ce ce type 2d
mission d'affrontements ce soit un peu
effacé il revient il revient dans des
paroles et des actes notamment la france
2 et on se dit voilà peut-être que c'est
ça qui est peut être utile pour relancer
l'intérêt du téléspectateur
tout simplement parce qu'il ya de
l'émotion il ya de la tension et il n'a
envie de participer à l'émission de
cette manière c'est peut-être aussi que
à un moment la communication
sur tous surpassés et qui font des
femmes et donc les hommes politiques
devaient pas tellement intérêt à se
confronter les uns les autres ils
n'avaient pas intérêt à se confronter
inhalé n'est pas non plus un intérêt aux
interviews longue 1 on s'aperçoit que
les hommes politiques au fur et à mesure
du temps viennent sur les plateaux de
télévision et plateau du 20 heures parce
qu'ils prennent un risque moindre que
face à des journalistes politiques et
préfèrent les formats courts au format
long dur le bon format aujourd'hui pour
un homme politique c'est set fut minutes
un peu plus merci infiniment christian
delporte je renvoie à votre livre donc
les grands débats politiques ces
émissions qui ont fait l'opinion c'est
chez flammarion merci beaucoup danser
vous